[Musique]
ce que j'aimais c'était pour rendez vous
est ce que tu es sur internet
par téléphone aux côtés des fois mais je
n'ai des choses
et puis ya des
découvrir l'hôtel pas savoir ce que
j'allais tomber
c'était comme un jeu
[Musique]
à
m
sur maman je ressentais presque rien
mais quand j'y repensais à près de
maison ou au lycée j'avais envie de
recommencer
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
où
quand vous avez fait pour commencer
elle a suivi un chaton du lycée il me
proposa large
donc c'est après manger ici en soie gris
c'est sur wii fait passer jeudi
notre avis
avec eux la
la journée du
tu sais
raconte rien la mer
[Musique]
ici l'histoire votre film est d'une
double vie madame elle se prostitue
[Musique]
aussi j'ai ton argent ciel gris petit
l'intention de continuer
je sais pas
et vous avez quel âge vraiment 17 au
chat en ménage
et